Last year, a certain place in my city,
Jakarta, was attacked by a suicide bomber.
Let’s imagine this event happened
inside a superhero comic book.
The villain, in this case,
a suicide bomber, arrives at the scene.
He walks around,
surveying the people and the place.
Once he is settled, all he needs to do
is press this little the red button
and "boom," everything blows up,
people are running away,
kids are screaming,
police and ambulance sirens
can be heard from every direction.
Suddenly, the superhero with his cape or
her shining armor comes and saves the day.
They help civilians to safety,
puts out the fire,
takes the injured to a hospital,
and most importantly, defeats the villain.
We all love these stories, don't we?
We all grew up hearing stories of heroism,
especially superheroes -
how Captain America with all his loyalty
and super strength,
he can save the world
and win hearts of everyone,
and how Batman using all his money creates
super gadgets to save his city, Gotham.
Tell me, who doesn’t love them?
Who doesn’t dream to be saved by them
even though you know they’re fictional?
Admit it, all of you
must have dreamt about it.
But those heroes, the Avengers,
Batman, Superman,
they have their own place to be a hero.
They have their own stories where they put
up their shining armor or capes or tights
and you know, save the world.
But in the end, they are only stories.
They don't exist
in the real world we live in.
So who then,
are the everyday heroes among us?
They don’t wear capes or tights
or have any superpowers
so what do they look like?
The dictionary says a hero is someone
who is admired for their courage, noble
qualities and outstanding achievements.
But to me, I think that heroes are people
who have the courage to help other people.
As simple as that.
It can be if the person just smiles at a
stranger, to me that is an act of heroism.
Why?
Because we never know
what the person might be going through
and smiling at a stranger
takes strength and effort.
It takes effort to put aside
our doubts of smiling at a stranger.
It takes strength to share the same
feelings with others, to have empathy.
There are a lot of heroes in real life,
Like Malala, Abraham Lincoln,
Martin Luther King,
Soekarno, Indonesia’s first president,
and a whole bunch of others.
And if I ask you what made them a hero,
most of us will say,
let's take an example, Malala,
most of us will say, “She’s a hero because
she fights for girls education,"
"She’s a hero because
she sacrificed herself,"
or maybe another example,
Martin Luther King.
“He’s a hero because he fought for freedom
for people of color."
She fought for this, he fought for that
and the whole list goes on.
But really though,
let’s take a moment and think about it.
All the heroes I just mentioned
and the heroes we all know,
have helped other people.
Malala helped girls to have education.
Martin Luther King helped people of color
to gain greater freedom
and equality in the United States.
They all believe in equality and that
everyone should get the same chances.
They have the vision to make
this world a better place.
You see, as we grow up,
we realize that life
is much harder
and tougher than it looks.
And we humans are social creatures.
We need each other in order to survive,
we need each other in order to live.
We need each other to be our heroes.
Heroes come in different shapes and sizes.
We don’t need to have superpowers
to be heroes.
We don’t need to have
a lot of money to be heroes.
We don't need to stand in front of a gun
to be a hero.
We don’t need to sacrifice ourselves
to death to be a hero.
But we do have to be kind
to be a hero.
We have to be helpful to be a hero.
We have to be empathetic to be a hero.
We have to do all these things
and other good things to be a hero.
These traits seem simple but it
actually takes time to practice.
So what if we start practicing for the day
when we can be heroes?
What if we had a hero-training?
Going back to what happened
in Jakarta last year,
I think that no matter how long we waited
for that superhero with his cape
or her shining armor to come,
they wouldn't because the real hero
in this event wasn’t them,
it was the people who decided fear
wouldn’t bring them down
and helped other people, instead.
I used to think my hero
is Superman and Batman.
Trust me, no joke. I have this huge photo
frame filled with my photos and theirs.
And then as I got older,
I stare at it and think.
I think that there are more people who
have been there for me through it all.
And the thing about life,
it has its own ups and downs
in which there are some moments
where we feel like stopping,
maybe like throwing up.
But there is someone who shared
the same ride with me
through my ups and down
and that is my mother.
She has no cape, no superpowers,
no exploding bank account.
She is just another human being.
But she is there for me.
She guided me and she helped me.
She is the reason
I am standing here today,
so can I say that she is my hero?
Yes, I can.
I looked around at how
I might become a hero,
and the best example I could find
wasn’t wearing a cape - it was my mother.
She is a hero because she's there
for me to rely on.
for me to wipe away my tears.
She is my hero because she is there
for me to make me smile.
This is just one story we can take
into our hero-training,
and I wanted to figure out this hero
formula so that I can share with you all.
So I did an experiment.
I spent three days looking
for hero-makers.
Here’s what I saw.
One day, my friend was crying in class.
People around her were telling her
"to get over it, don't think about it,
it doesn't matter, you're overreacting."
But then this other friend came to her
and gave her a hug.
Just support, no advice,
no talking, just support.
That's hero lesson number one.
Heroes are always looking out for others.
My friend didn’t tell her
what she should feel
because to be honest the only one
who know how it truly feels
is my friend who was crying.
So instead, she thought about what
she might need at that moment.
That’s empathy.
The second example is my school nurse was
walking down the street with her baby
and a toddler beside her.
She struggled to put everything
onto her motorbike,
but then when she finally managed
to put her children in,
she almost dropped her bag until a man
came to her and decided to help her.
That's hero lesson number two.
Sometimes it doesn’t require
a great action to be a hero.
A small gesture like this deserves
to be called a hero action.
There are a lot more stories
we can learn from
and we can add into our hero training,
But there is one lesson that
I learned from these events
and that is sometimes the small gestures
are the ones that matter the most.
It is the way we smile at others
that can make us a hero.
Because you would never know,
maybe our smile is the only
good thing they had that day.
It was the way we hug our family
and friends that makes us a hero.
It is the way we give a hand to others
when they needed help
with their groceries.
It is the way we make somebody else smile
that makes us a hero.
So I think that being a hero isn’t all
about having a lot of money
or wearing capes or wearing shining armor
and doing great things
and changing the world.
I think that being a hero is about being
kind, helpful, generous, and empathetic.
These are the things we should
do in our hero training.
These are the things we should do
in our daily life as a good human being
and as a hero.
Now, we can all start training today.
Do you want to be your version
of Captain Kindness?
Or maybe you want to have
your own empathetic-mobile like Batman?
Or maybe you can be everything by yourself
and be an Avenger.
It is all up to you.
If the answer to these questions
is yes then you know what you have to do.
Go out there, pick a color of your cape,
and be a hero.
Thank you.